ok I want to talk about something that's
been coming up more and more I'm getting
more and more tweets and emails and
comments not calling me a Jew liar that
the number of those is relatively stable
you'll be pleased to know Pat but more
and more tweets and emails and comments
on YouTube saying something along the
lines of hey David
you should be thanking Trump not
complaining about him because his
presidency is helping shows like yours
this is absolutely and completely
correct at least the part that as I said
before the election I don't want Trump
to win I thought it would have been best
for the country that Trump not be
president but I'm aware that if Trump
had won I was aware that if Trump won
I'm aware that because Trump did win
it's way better for programs like the
David Pakman show there's no doubt about
that but so then what right I should
pretend as though I support Trump's
politics because he's been good for our
show I should not criticize his
atrocious behavior and his lack of
competence and lack of fitness to serve
as president because yeah our audience
has grown and our membership has grown
as people have rallied around and
organized against the President of the
United States and the reason I'm talking
about it today is because I'm seeing it
more and more it's being said to me with
a higher and higher frequency David your
show is growing as fast as it is because
of Trump so lay off the criticism of him
what sense does that make
right if there's one thing that I do
hear it's that I call it the way I see
it no matter who's in office no matter
what is going on right it doesn't even
compute to me that because Trump being
president rather than Hillary being
president has helped us to grow my
coverage Trump should be adjusted in
that way I don't even understand what
argument it is that's being made if the
logic doesn't hold up because if you're
saying that our criticisms of Trump is
what is making the show be successful
wouldn't we want to continue that rather
than praise him if we started praising
him then I think our viewership would go
down well there's value to being in the
opposition right it's very different
doing a show it was very different doing
the David Pakman show under the George W
Bush administration than it was under
the Obama administration but
that doesn't mean that we didn't have
endless criticisms of President Obama
but it's a different type of criticism
when you are I guess sort of closer to
the politics of the person in the White
House what kind of program would it be
if I said well this Trump thing has been
so good for us that we should really lay
off the guy and kind of like pretend
he's doing good things know being in the
opposition to Trump is part of why
people are choosing to be solid you know
to using solidarity with us being in the
opposition has a sort of cachet that is
unique and beneficial but we've been
doing this too long to change the scope
of the show based on who's in office we
praise those in office when they deserve
praise no matter who they are we
criticize those in office when that's
what's called for period I even actually
started getting emails passing David the
reason you're saying it's better for
Democrats if Trump stays in isn't
because Mike Pence would be worse it's
because you need Trump so that your show
can is growing the show's been growing
for ten years right Donald Trump wasn't
president for most of that time I
believe that it could backfire for Trump
to leave genuinely I honestly believe
that the left might benefit from a
scandal-ridden Trump staying in the Oval
Office and yet every day we have more
evidence that the guy truly isn't fit to
serve so if the correct course of action
is removal then it's removal but the
idea that I'm carefully crafting the
narrative of the show to have maximum
appeal at any given time if that was the
case I would have come up with dishonest
positions on other issues that would
have been more palpable to our audience
right on circumcision a lot of our
audience doesn't like my position on
circumcision if I wanted to take the
path of least resistance I would lie
about my position on circumcision which
is according to medical experts benefits
outweigh the risks I could have picked a
different position on the
israeli-palestinian conflict if I didn't
want to irritate some people on the left
or on Venezuela these are all areas
where if the the mo of this program was
do what is going to just be most
appealing to people then I would have
taken very different positions all along
if I've never
it before why would I start with Trump
so I find the criticism to be totally
bogus but you're right we're doing way
better because Trump won and Hillary
lost that's true
yeah we've been upfront about that I
remember when the tax plan was being
debated yeah we said that this could
actually be good for the David Pakman
show
but we're opposed to it because it's bad
for the country no question about it the
pass-through income provisions are good
for anyone who owns an S corporation
like the David Pakman show but morally I
was opposed to that so anyway give it a
rest all right and we're not changing
the show and we haven't changed the show
because of any of these whims I'm just
doing the show and doing every story the
way I see it